Speaker 1: Speaking of the fecklessness of
Republicans and their inability to do the
right thing in the face of wrongdoing of lies.
George Santos. This. He's the gift that keeps
on giving. It is crazy to me that more is
not being said of republic by Republicans,
that there's not a movement afoot to at least
rein this guy in. And now, because of of intrepid
reporters doing investigative work, we're finding
out that it is likely that there's there is a
there there. It is likely that he is going to find
his day in court and maybe be removed. I think
it's unlikely. I think that the investigation and
any prosecution that would take place would would
take far longer than his term in office for this
two years. But the Mother Jones just did a piece
about his his donor base. And they looked at his
his several of his donors in the 2020 election,
many of which dozens. Maybe they they
don't exist. They can't find these people.
And I'm going to read kind of a summation here
from The Daily Beast, but you really should go
seek out this article from from Mother Jones,
because it is detailed and they go through who
the names are and what their addresses are,
and they tried to reach out. Some of these
addresses don't even exist. Some of the people
they did reach out to who did answer the phone,
who do exist, said we didn't give that money. And
so the question is because the money was given.
Just not by the people that the names were listed.
So who gave the money and why did they give the
money to get this nut in office? People don't just
give freely of their treasure to get George Santos
elected without getting something in return. And
these are all questions that are coming out. I
mean, look, we all laughed. We all made our jokes
about him lying about his mother dying on 911,
about her dying on the 23rd of December. And that
was our fifth year anniversary, about him having
two knee replacements and being a volleyball star
to college. He didn't go to about his name being
Anthony de Valda. All of the insane lies that he
told that were absolutely most certainly going to
be found out. But this goes to a different level
of corruption and criminality, allegedly likely,
I believe. And getting to the bottom of this is
important. Now, you can't rely upon Republicans
to do that because Kevin McCarthy gave him
committee assignments, gave him more credibility,
more legitimacy. But I'm going to read this
summation from The Daily Beast here. Some of
George Santos top donors apparently don't even
exist. Report says more than two dozen major
donations to George Santos 2020 congressional
campaign came from donors who appear to not exist,
according to an investigation by Mother Jones.
Santos congressional campaign reported in 2020
that Victoria and Jonathan Rigger had each maxed
out by contributing 20 $800 to his campaign.
But no one in the United States has either name,
according to the report. And the address listed
also doesn't exist. More than $30,000 of the
money raised for Santos. This campaign came
from people who don't appear to exist. Although
it's illegal to donate money to a campaign under
a false name. One donor who told Mother Jones
he's a friend of Santos, said he didn't make
the 20 $800 donation Santos listed on his FEC
filing. The questionable funding reveal comes
as the FEC considers a criminal probe of Santos
over his newly listed campaign treasurer, who has
claimed he isn't actually the congressman's
treasurer. Now, this is the 2020 campaign.
When they start digging. My guess would be he
didn't get any more clear or accurate in his
campaign filings. We already know that he was
filing dozens and dozens and dozens and dozens
of campaign expenditures that were just under
the limit before he had to provide a receipt,
$199.99. There were dozens of them for Uber
rides, one whole day of Uber rides of of $200,
199 99. The next day, another 199 99 and
Uber rides in flights, in trip insurance,
in restaurants, and just a panoply of lies
from George Santos. So this isn't just a case
of a guy who lied about his background. There's
real questions, real things to find out related
to how he got his money. Who gave it to him
and what they want for it. We'll certainly
continue to follow this case as journalists
do the good work of investigating wrongdoing
by this particular clown. Once again, I am Jesse
Dallimore, host of Dollar More Daily on YouTube.
You can catch me on Twitter at Dallimore and you
can listen to my podcast. I doubt it on anywhere
that podcasts are found. We're also on Twitter
there. I doubt it. Podcast. Thanks for joining me.